the house of wolves trailer just dropped
with the release date of May nineteenth
and we're going to do a trailer
breakdown there's actually a lot of
story behind this trailer even though
it's very short it shows a lot of things
so the first guy who we see here no not
this guy this round spherical guy here
he's probably gone in calyx prime for
those who don't know the back start of
the queen she basically killed the Kehl
who's the ruler of the house of walt and
took over all their troops and the Prime
got away this guy and she's been hunting
him ever since so this story is largely
going to focus on his revenge story well
its revenge story at the robot so the
cool thing is the first environment we
see here is a snowy planet it's clearly
not the reef and it's clearly not in
space there's an atmosphere there's ice
crystals that would indicate to us that
this is probably Saturn's moon Titan
which is one of the only grimoire cards
that also references the reef now the
important thing about that is the primes
looking for something it's probably i'm
going to guess the prison of elders the
Queen basically has this giant supermax
prison that's full of fallen leadership
royalty and some of the kind of leftover
threats to her from the house of wolf so
it'd make a lot of sense that calyx was
basically looking to jailbreak the rest
of the house of wolves in order to take
back power from the Queen the next shot
that we see is the Queen's Guard all
murdered and stuff the interesting thing
is the shot after that is the Queen's
brother kind of looking menacingly over
her shoulder now the Queen's brother has
his own agenda which was clear in the
original destiny storyline for example
he wanted to use the black garden for
their purposes as a weapon instead of
destroy it and he got overruled by his
sister the interesting question is
basically did the brother betray the
queen is that how the Queen's Guard got
killed and the house of wolves had their
breakout oh
the reef to the Guardians offer the
riches of our realm as bounty for these
traitors now towards the end of the
trailer the Queen talks about opening
the reef to guardians and offering its
riches this is a really risky play by
her at this point the speaker has been
essentially conquering the solar system
and expanding out with his Guardians
he's already killed crota he's already
destroyed the heart of the black garden
and it's very clear that the asteroid
belt has all of the Golden Age riches
and tons of ore and things that they
need to mine so the speaker is not
stupid at this point I'm assuming he
knows that he's going to need the
asteroid belt if he wants to continue
expanding this Guardian Empire I have
shown you benevolence guardian should
the awoken never need an ally I will
call on you and expect you to answer now
what's interesting about this expansion
is that the Queen and her brother were
two of the only actually developed
characters and destiny eros should have
been more developed she should have been
a more untrustworthy quest giver but she
ended up just basically having you do or
laundry I'm not super confident that
bungees gonna actually tell the Queen
story properly but if they do it's cool
because she's not somebody who has the
Guardians best interest in mind she's
definitely just looking after herself
and again her brother who may be back
stabbing her is also looking after his
own interests so that could lead to some
really interesting story telling there's
no way that basically after you've taken
care of her dirty laundry she would ever
allow Guardians to just remain in her
realm finally just to get everybody
caught up who don't know about the reef
the quick back story on that is its
where the humans who fled earth ended up
getting mostly annihilated when they
escaped during the fall essentially when
the traveler blew its stack it's light
push all the darkness out that's
probably what actually made the awoken
turn into what they are now there's
going to be a new social hub there so
you'll actually get to walk around and
explore it a bit so some of that you'll
be able to interact with on a side note
one of the factions dead orbit is busy
building a fleet to escape the solar
system there but I I sincerely doubt
that that will get touched on so those
are break down to the house of wolves
trailer if you notice anything that we
didn't cover feel free to say it in the
comments below otherwise house of wolves
will be out May nineteen
in the end they all bow before me
you